all right so it's on all right what up
guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to my
interview Series so
today
um I have a special guest on the channel
Rachel Wilson now for those of you that
don't know I actually interviewed Rachel
um last week the video hasn't come out
yet it's in the pipeline it's coming
um but I interviewed her about her book
um it's called occult feminism and it's
actually about the true history of
feminism but but today
um I'm actually not going to be talking
at all about feminism and the question I
had for Rachel so Rachel is um she's a
mother of five
and she was a stay-at-home mother and
she also homeschooled her children
and what I wanted to know is let's say
you're a woman that wants to start a
family and wants to go down that route
we constantly hear that we need two
incomes in order to support a family but
I've also done a little bit of research
and I've spoken to mothers and a lot of
them are telling me that no it's not as
expensive to raise kids as these people
are saying and this is just the
narrative that they push trying to get
mothers to work now I don't necessarily
know what's true and what's false so I
decided to bring Rachel on the channel
to give her take on
what number so if you're a woman right
we don't want the girls dating bums okay
we there's nobody in the manosphere I
know we have the anti-gold Digger stuff
you know but women we have to gold dig a
little bit let's just be honest like we
can't date men with no jobs all right so
um
I wanted to know
what income so if you're a girl and
you're 21 and you say I want to be a
mother and raise a family
how much money does he need to make
and where do you need to live and how
how do you structure your life in order
to do that like if I could if I could go
back in time and be 21 fresh out of
school so welcome welcome to the show
Rachel I'm pulling you up now thanks for
having me on
well this is
strongly feel like
women are propagandized constantly to
believe that all kinds of things about
motherhood that aren't true that it's
too expensive that you'll regret it if
you you know have all these kids and
don't have a career and that it's
dangerous and risky to have children
because you won't be financially secure
and it there's a ton of factors to
consider just because of the way things
are in the United States and probably
even in in Europe it depends where you
live how much things cost and things
like that but there's definitely ways
definitely ways to raise multiple kids
have a large family and if you want to
stay home with your kids to make that
work
um I have a whole bunch of data and
statistics for you but we should
probably just kind of start with how did
we get to the point where it's told to
everybody that we need two incomes to
survive right because it that's a new
thing it was never like that in all of
human history prior to about 1980 is
really when things change and that's
because from 1960 to 1980 the workforce
almost doubled because of participation
in the labor force by women by married
women and mothers who previously rarely
were in the labor force so if we're
talking about the early 20th century
prior to suffrage
it was a very tiny amount of women who
were married that worked outside the
home was only about 12 percent so once
you got married it was kind of expected
you would stay home and you'd probably
be a mom and then that number began to
rise more and more as the 20th century
went on and as women's Liberation
propaganda got out there and then World
War II happened
and we had a lot of women go into the
workforce to cover for men who had gone
to the war but after the war most of
them went back home and that was what
the 40s yes that was the late 40s and um
the 60s is when things really started to
change because the Ford foundation and
the Rockefeller Foundation started to
create women's studies departments and
universities and they put massive
amounts of funding into women's suffrage
propaganda and women's Liberation
propaganda telling women that you know
it's very risky to be married and you
should have your own money and you
should have your own credit because what
if he leaves you or what if he becomes
an abuser suddenly that abuse mode just
flips on one day and he becomes like
this awful man and then you're trapped
right and you even saw a lot of that in
Pulp pop culture in the 70s with movies
like The Stepford Wives where and there
was a bunch of them there's a whole
series of movies that came out that made
it seem like enough wife and mom was
like boring and and unfulfilling that
being a career woman was exciting and
cool and that was what like the 60s is
that when the movies came out sort of
like the late 60s and then through the
70s so in just a short period of time
about 20 years we saw just a huge
movement of women into the labor force
and it's hard to find comprehensive data
that proves one way or the other the
effect that had but the most
comprehensive study that's been done on
it was in 2002
um
and it was autor Lyle and ASA moglu
that's a hard word to say sorry
um they did this massive study and they
used the exogenous variation in female
labor Supply before and after World War
II that's a very fancy way of saying how
did women jumping into the workforce and
then leaving again affect things and one
of the things they found was that for
every 10 increase in women's
participation in labor you saw men's
wages go down three to five percent
and another little piece that helps kind
of lend credibility and and backs this
up is that in 1930s Germany a lot of
women started entering the labor force
in factories
and they actually had such high rates of
male unemployment and depressed wages
for men and even rises in male suicide
that the German government had some laws
put in that married women it put
restrictions on married women working
because they wanted men to be able to
have a living wage and support a family
because their birth rate was going down
and they didn't want that
so
um there's a whole lot of reasons why
women believe this and there's some
truth to it because it we don't have a
family wage anymore we have an
individual wage now
so that's why in the 50s if you were a
janitor you could support like four kids
and a wife and your wife could stay home
that's pretty tough to do now although
there are ways to do it
um one thing is pay attention to where
you live I have uh data here from the
USDA which has tracked the cost of
raising a child since 1960 and they say
the most expensive places in the United
States to raise children is the urban
Northeast
and the most affordable places would be
in the rural and Suburban Midwest and
then the South so if you're outside of a
big city your housing costs go down your
daycare costs go down basically the cost
of living in general is lower and you
can probably get bigger a bigger house
for a lot less money in a place like
that so that would be like a very big
determining factor and also in those
places the wages for like men's jobs
industrial jobs
um trade jobs it's like kind of the
Bread Basket and the last remaining
sector where we have factories men can
get a pretty good wage in those places
compared to large cities where it might
be there might be more competition it
might be more difficult for men to get a
higher paying wage relative to the cost
of living
so my personal advice if you want to
stay home with your kids if you're young
and you're contemplating career versus
being a mom or like how do I balance
those
I think we give people we give women
backwards advice we tell them to go to
college get into a bunch of debt start a
career build a career and then after all
of that then you can think about getting
married and having kids well there's a
bunch of problems with that one is that
you're going to end up having your kids
much older one another problem is you've
got now that you've got this college
debt you want to pay it off so the
thought of quitting your jobs right
because because you've got student loan
debt to pay right right
so but this is what's happened and the
effects of that are that we've had a
huge drop in the birth rate since 1958
1960 when women started entering the
workforce the average woman had 3.58
children in 1958 by 2019 that number has
gone down to 1.3 wow
so 1.3 and what you said it was three
point what
3.58 so over the last 50 years the
global fertility rate has been chopped
in half wow yeah that's a result of
women having kids much older the average
age that women would you know have a
baby
does the average woman have that's the
other question that's a lot too so isn't
that like one out of isn't it like one
out of three women have had an abortion
yes wow and um MSI is the UK version of
Planned Parenthood they average about 5
million abortions a year
um in the United States I think it's
right it's been right around a million
1.21.3 million wow it'd be so
interesting to factor in like if they
had those children what the birth rate
would be it'd be so interesting it would
be higher
um yeah and the average age women are
having their first child now is 30. wow
and it used to be like 20 21 years ago
so if you start when you're 30 you can't
have you having more than one or two is
just really unlikely that just becomes
really untenable so another really
important thing I think people should
know is that between 1950 and 2010 the
rate of welfare spending in both the UK
and the United States has gone up at the
same exact rate as out of wedlock births
isn't that interesting wow so the more
out of wedlock bursts we have our
welfare spending goes up and if you look
at the two plotted out on a graph they
go up like this just in perfect lock
step with one another
so I mean we have a lot of good
statistics a lot of good data a lot of
good math that can't really be argued
with this shows that the more we
encourage women that they must focus on
Career the harder it becomes for them to
even look at motherhood as an option do
you know what I mean so if you wait till
your 30s your odds of having fertility
problems go up your odds of having a
child with complications or
um you know birth defects goes up so
that makes raising kids more expensive
as well as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible